good morning John it's your brother Hank
I have news if you follow me on social
media you may have already seen it but
my book a beautifully foolish endeavor
has a cover designed by the marvelous
Kaitlin call it's a real thing now is
the book done done no it's the book done
enough that I can read you the first
chapter yes it is this is a mock-up of
the book it's not the real thing but I
have taped the words of the first
chapter inside of it so here is the
first chapter of my second book a
beautifully foolish endeavor a sequel to
an absolutely remarkable thing chapter
one I have decided to stop lying to you
as far as I can tell there are only
three kinds of lie the kind you don't
want to get caught telling the kind you
don't care if you get caught telling and
the kind you can't get caught telling
let's go through them one by one one the
kind you don't want to get caught
telling this is just your average
everyday lie whether you're late for
work or did a real bad murder getting
caught in the lies us is a problem too
the kind you don't care if you get
caught telling this kind of lie is about
the lying not about outcome you repeat
the lies stick to the lied change the
lie reform the lie abandon the lie come
back to the lie the lying might help you
avoid some negative outcome but really
it's a tool for weakening reality and
thus strengthening yourself 3 the kind
of lie you can't get caught telling this
happens when only you know the truth
this is the kind of lie I've been
telling for years now this last kind of
lie has felt to me like a kindness I
mean it's not a surprise that the story
of your reality is incomplete we all
know that scientists don't know where
most of the matter is I don't know what
it's like to live in Yemen our imagining
of the world isn't fully accurate but if
you know something no one else knows
something that would change everyone's
story overnight something that would
make everyone else's life worse telling
the truth might seem like the wrong
thing to do like exercising too much
power
as I have discovered there's nothing
special about me that means I'm
particularly suited to making that kind
of decision for an entire planet of
people the only reason I get to make it
it turns out is ugly vulgar luck a lot
of people have said that I have a habit
of exercising too much power and one of
those people is me which is why I'm
about to do something I'm extremely
uncomfortable with let other people tell
the story Oh to be clear I don't have a
choice
I wasn't there for a lot of this so it
isn't my story to tell which is why
you're about to hear the story from
several different perspectives maybe
that way we can share some of the
responsibilities of the power of this
truth it won't be all on me all of us
have to agree that the words in this
book are worth putting in here oh this
is to say I've decided to stop lying to
you we have decided to stop lying to you
even though the lie is easy to tell even
though I never really said it out loud
even though the lie most days feels like
nothing more than self-preservation it's
time to tell you about the lie here it
is in its most basic form I have been
doing everything I can to make you
believe that everything is going to be
okay maybe that's not quite what you're
hoping for with a sequel maybe you
wanted chapter 3 which is where some
questions start getting answered but
that day is not today that day is July
7th 2020 but you don't have to wait till
then to pre-order the book you could do
that now so if you want to come see live
dear Hank and John and live anthropocene
reviewed and a couple of other
weirdnesses John and I are going to be
in st. Petersburg Florida Raleigh North
Carolina and Atlanta Georgia in early
January come on out tickets in the
description John I'll see you on Tuesday